Çok
[Müzik]
teşekkürler
Merhaba
uzun
Geçende dirgin verici
kısıtlayıcı evlerde kapalı kaldığımız
bir sürecin sonunda bugün burada yeniden
eski normal lerimize geri dönerken
sizlerle beraber olabilmek ve için çok
anlamlı iyi ki varsınız tüm organizasyon
ekibine beni davet ettikleri için çok
teşekkür ediyorum
Evet mimari bu Tanrım sürecinde Mask
elenen Mimarlık tarihi birikimi üzerine
Ben de bugünkü tedex konuşmalarının
genel teması maske
olan
bir konuşma yapmak istedim ve gelin
mimari tasarım sürecinde Mimarlık tarihi
bilgi birikiminin maskesini beraber
kaldıralım
Evet bildiğiniz gibi bi Mimarlık tarihi
iki temel disiplinden beslenmekte bir
tanesi Benim de lisans eğitimi almış
olduğum mimarlık ve Mimarlık lisans
eğitimi bittiği zaman uzun gecen bol
kahveli gecelerin sonucunda iki kuvvetli
tasarım ce mimarın çocuğu olarak ben de
kendime kuvvetli bir gelecek
bu şekli bir kariyer planlaması yapmak
istedim ve bunun içinde biraz daha
ebeveynlerinden farklı bir yola
girmeyi tercih ettim ama biliyordum ki
bu yoğun Aslında beni iyi bir tasarımcı
Mimar olmaya götürecekti Mimarlık tarihi
bilgi birikiminin diğer dayandığı alan
tarih bildiğiniz gibi burada tabii Eğer
benim sınıflarında olsaydık karşılıklı
pek çok sorulu cevaplı bir süreç
geçirecektir bunu bu burada bu şekilde
inşa etmem söz konusu olamayacak ama
sizlere şunu soracağım acaba tarih ve
geçmiş aynı şey midir Kendi içinizde
cevap aradığınızı şu anda biliyorum ben
sizler için cevaplamaya çalışayım tarih
ve geçmiş aynı şey değildir ama Bizler
Hayat içerisinde yaşarken Eğer bu iki
kavramı üst üste algılama eylemin deyiz
dir geçmiş aslında
bir süreçtir Şu andan önce yaşanmış olan
her şeyi içerir tarih s Aslında geçmişte
olan olayların
bir bilgi birikimi dağarcığında
belgelere bulgulara kızı raporlarına
arşiv dökümantasyon una mevcut olan
tarihi yapı envanterleri ne dayalı
olarak kaleme alınmasıdır kimler
tarafından tarih yazarları tarafından
Dolayısıyla tarih
aslında geçmişin yazılı hali Yani bir
yazım etkinliğidir
Peki bu bilgiler bize Şimdi nereye
taşıyacak
tarih tarih ya bu ne şekilde yapılır
tarih yazımı Aslında her tarih yazarının
takmış olduğuydu gözlükten bakarak
yazılır Bu ne demek
Her birimizin kişisel tarihselliği var
Bizler toplum içerisinde yaşayan
bireyler olarak kişisel tarihselciliğe
sahibiz gelin Buna cevap arayalım
bir aile içerisinde
Aynı yumurta ikizi olarak doğduğumuzu
düşünün ve çocukluğunuzdan itibaren
doğduğunuz andan şu anda gelirken okumuş
olduğunuz her okulda Bulunmuş olduğunuz
her sınıfta ikiziniz ve beraber
bulunduğumuzu düşünün yine de sizin
karakteriniz ikiziniz den farklı
olacaktır İşte bu kişisel tarihselliği
midir ama Bizler doğduğumuz andan şu ana
kadar gelirken sırtımızda birer kişisel
tarihsellik sırt çantası taşırız ve bu
çanta içerisine yaşantı içerisinde
Yaşadığımız her türlü tecrübeyi iyi
koyarız yaşantı içerisinde
karşılaşmış olduğumuz arkadaşlık
larımızı hislerimizi üzüntülerimizi
mutluluk larımızı yani Bizi biz yapan
her türlü unsuru bu çantanın içerisinde
Barındırır İşte bu çanta içerisindeki
unsurların birbirinden farklı olması
bizim kişisel Kimliğimizi ortaya
çıkartır Bu da bizim kişisel
tercihlerimizin kişisel bakış açımızı
birbirinden neden farklı olduğunu
gösterecektir
Dolayısıyla
geçmişi yani Bizler Az önce yaşanmış
olan süreci bir tarih Yazım etkinliğine
çevirirken biz işte o kişisel
tarihsellik çantamızda bizim
kişiliğimizi oluşturan
unsurlar çerçevesinde siyasi görüşümüz
de kimi zaman
beğenilerim izle kimi zaman kızgınlıklar
ımıza kimi zaman cinsel tercihimize yani
Bizi biz yapan herşeyle Aslında tarihi
yazarız Biz objektif olması beklenen bir
bilgi alanıdır ama buradan takdir ederek
anlayacağınız gibi
subjektiftir
bir kişisel tarihi eserlerimizin
uzantısı olarak
baktığımız
gözlüklerimiz dünyayı algılamış
olduğumuz algı süreci as bu birbirinden
farklı olduğu için bugün
yaratmış olduğumuz bir anlatı
konstrüksiyonu dur kısaca tarih
Peki biz tasarımlarımızı yaparken bu
tarih bilgi birikiminden nasıl
besleniriz acaba bu birbirinden çok
farklı gözüken iki alan ne şekilde
birbirinin Eslem ben ya da daha farklı
bir şekilde bu soruyu soracak olursak
mimari tasarım süreci içerisinde üzeri
maskelenmiş olan aslında Çok da
farkında olmadığımız o Mimarlık tarihi
bilgi birikimi bizi nasıl daha iyi
tasarımcı haline getirir
Biraz önce da anlattığım gibi aslında
insan
Bu tarihseldir bir kişisel tarihsellik
durumunun uzantısı olarak kendi
karakterini kontör yükle etmektedir
toplum içerisinde Mimarlık pratiği de
meslek olarak tarihseldir ta
insanoğlunun mağaraları ilk kullandığı
zamanlarda orayı mekan olarak
algılayarak
duvarlarına resimleri kendin denizleri
daha sonraki nesillere aktarılacağı
biçimde bıraktığı andan itibaren
Mimarlık tarihi süreci başlamıştır İnsan
mekanla ilk kez orada yüzleş miştir ve o
andan çok
uzun bir süreç olarak bu ana kadar gelen
ve içerisinde birbirinden çok farklı
üslupları kronolojik olarak içeren mi
zty sağlık tarihi bilgi birikimi ile
beslenen mimari tasarım süreci de
dolayısıyla tarihseldir bir Aslında
fiziksel çevremizi oluşturan her şey Bu
bağlamda tarihseldir
Bugün bir İçinde bulunduğumuz salon gibi
bir kongre merkezinin konferans salonunu
tasarlamak durumundaysa nız
sizden önce yapılmış olan iyi ve kötü
örnekleri bilmek durumundasınız hem de
iyi bir şekilde bilmek durumundasınız
iyi şekilde irdelemek durumdasınız iyi
olan örnekler sizden önce yapılmış iyi
olan örnekler ver niye gösterir size
doğru sonuçları sizden önce yapılmış
kötü örnekler s Ne yapmamız gerekeni
neleri daha iyi daha doğru yapmanız
gerektiğini gösterirler Dolayısıyla Eğer
sizin
tarih Bilginiz Mimarlık alanında
kuvvetli ise
Siz daha rahat tasarım yapabilirsiniz
konuyu biraz daha genişletelim
Bizler genellikle Beher tasarım
problemini sıfır noktasından
gerçekleştirdik sonrası içerisindeyiz
Yani
tam
16-17 yüzyıla kadar geriye gidersek bir
tabular ağzı boş bir levha üzerinde
tasarımlarımızı yaptığımızı bızı
sağlamaktayız
Oysa ki bizler düğmesi şu an robotlar
değiliz
Dolayısıyla düğme mize bastığımız zaman
kapanıp bastığımız zaman açılmıyor Uz Bu
bağlamda da işte Az önce anlattığım gibi
sırtımızdaki o kişisel tarihselliği mi
taşıdığımız sırt çantamızda ki
tarihselliği mize dayanarak tüm o tarih
bilgi birikimiyle ile tasarımlarımızı
yapmaya başlıyoruz Yani aslında
Tasarımın 10 noktası yoktur
bu imar kendisini yerleştirebilir
edeceği ya da yerleştirdiği bir mutlak
toplumsal tarihsel sürece eklemlenen
Erek üretim yapar bu Tap toplumsal
Tarihsel süreç içerisinde Aslında yine
doğduğumuz andan şu ana kadar gelirken
bizleri her yerde İmge havuzu bulunmakta
Bizler Aslında Hayat içerisinde yaşarken
bilinçli ya da bilinçsiz dışı yaşantı
içerisinde gördüğümüz etüt o ettiğimiz
her şeyi her imgeyi bu İmge havuzumuza
kaydeden birer kayıt makinesi gibi
işlemek teyiz bildiğiniz gibi çoğu zaman
filmlerde ya da dizilerde bu özelliğimiz
kapitalist ekonomik düzenek içerisinde
kullanılmakta Sözüm Ona Siz bir Bruce
Willis Die hard serisine sinemaya gidip
ağır bir macera filmi seyretmek isteği
içerisindeyken Aslında hayatta hiç
karşılaşmadığımız bir
pembe dondurma isteğiyle o sinema
salonundan çıkıyorsanız
İşte bu kapitalist ekonomi Sen niye
Aslında sizin bu özelliğinizi bildiği
için Çünkü
sinemada seyretmiş olduğunuz filmin en
can alıcı noktasında
Bruce bir Zen maceranın yüksek
noktasında orada sahnede bulunurken
arkadan geçen bir pembe dondurma
kamyonundan ötürü Siz Aslında güdülenmiş
bulunuyorsunuz yani bilinçdışı o İmge
sizin ilgi havuzumuza girmiş oluyor
Dolayısıyla
Bizler bu şekilde birer kayıt makinesi
halinde çalışıyorsak
bilinçli olarak doğru imgeleri
bu İmge havuzumuza eklemek bize daha iyi
tasarımcı yapacaktır
Bu da aslında tarihi çevre içerisinde
ortaya koy o zaman tarihi yapıları daha
iyi bilmemizi gerektirir Bizler ne kadar
tarihi çevreden
haberdar Sak tarihi çevre içerisindeki
tarihi yapılarla dost Sak barışık sana
onları ne kadar iyi etüd ediyorsak
onları ne kadar iyi tanıyor Sak
tasarımlarımızı da çok daha iyi yapan
Mimarlar halinde
görevimize icra edebiliriz yani kısaca
hangi toplumsal tarihsel süreçlere
eklemlenen yapı ve Mimarlar nasıl mevcut
olmuş nelerle kavga vermiş nelerle
karşılıklı etkileşime geçmiş
Bu soruların cevapları tarihle
kurduğumuz ilişkilerde gizlidir ve
imgesel
hafızamızın genişliği Boyut ne olur bizi
aslında
burada görmüş olduğunuz gibi bi kuvvetli
tasarımlar ortaya koyan Mimarlar haline
getirirler Çok teşekkür ediyorum
şu m